welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's an awesome
day to be a Batman fan with us finally
getting reports that Jeffery rive will
be playing Commissioner Gordon in the
upcoming Matt Reeves Dark Knight film we
had lots of news outlets late last week
state that Wright was in talks to play
one of the Caped Crusader's greatest
allies and after Batman Day passed over
the weekend Wright made an enigmatic
tweet over one of the posts in the posts
he did the eye glass emoji which
everyone thought was the penguin
whichever fair enough I thought it was
the penguin however it looks like we
finally have confirmation that he will
in fact be the city's most famous
policeman The Hollywood Reporter broke
the news and this was followed up by
Collider and comic book calm that the
actor was indeed being eyed for the role
now personally I think this pretty much
confirms the news and this is a classic
strategy by Warner Brothers that we've
seen deployed in the past several times
as with the casting of Robert Pattinson
DC tend to put feelers out on the
internet before making official
announcements and this is been put in
place in my opinion purely to gauge the
reaction of the web which so far has
been pretty positive now when this is
officially confirmed which i think will
be in the next couple of days there's
two things that we can take from it one
the upcoming film will 100% not be
connected to the Batman V Superman
universe we did pretty much know this
already as DC are wanting to distance
themselves slightly from that however
this pretty much confirms it with JK
Simmons portraying him in the other
universe too as this is a film set in
the early days of Batman's history right
may not actually be Commissioner just
yet now the movie is based on the long
Halloween in which Gordon was not the
commissioner and was instead a captain
so similar to the Dark Knight trilogy
this film could potentially show his
rise through the ranks during the war on
crime as he can probably tell I'm very
excited by this news and I pretty much
love right and well everything that he's
in he's got a really commanding presence
so whether he's in source code The
Hunger Games or Westworld he's always
someone that leaves an impression and I
think that this is pretty great casting
now as always with things like this
there are some people crying out that
it's a race swap but honestly I really
think that right is perfect for the role
even if Gordon is traditionally
portrayed as a white man decisions like
this should always come down to who the
best actor for the role is and right
knocks it out of the park every single
time apparently the role was between
Wright and Muhammad Ali but the blade
movie got in the way for the latter but
even if it hadn't I still think that
Wright is far more suitable for the role
this is the second casting announcement
that we've had so far and the movie is
shaping up to be incredible hopefully
this signifies the announcement of more
casting to come in the following weeks
as we have rumors that Jonah Hill will
be playing the Riddler
though this remains to be seen now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this news and if you're excited for
the film or not comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of the best Easter egg
that you missed in all of the MCU movies
this is a little detail that ran from
Iron Man all the way up to Avengers
endgame so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come chat to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and make
sure you follow me on twitter at
definition whitey it's the best way to
get in touch with me and it's the
perfect place to suggest new videos and
topics so hopefully I see you over there
after this this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]